well we're all parents so i think it's
important i i learned in therapy it's
important to show your vulnerability
i've had like a rough two years and it's
hard sometimes if you get sick or if
something happens or whatever to show
you're kind of vulnerable to your kids
but it's actually really important that
we do that are you all good at that i
mean when i have cried they look at me
like
yeah you're crying there's tears coming
out of those eyeballs because they're
not used to that because you always try
to hold it in or hold it together but
then when it goes they're like they
can't believe it and they stare at
you're like yeah who are you
i did i held back because i was like
well i don't want them to like i know
they're gonna end up in therapy for
something but i didn't want that to be
the thing so i was i tried not to and my
favorite was like it's okay to like be
sad in front of kids or get hurt or like
not be invincible and that was like
really hard for me are you good at like
letting yourself i was really really bad
and also like i was a single mother
because i divorced when he was one year
old so i felt like i needed to be the
strong father and the mother at the same
time and i am a latin
woman so i was kind of if i could go
back i would be different i would be you
know more
i can't say that word bernard ball
vulnerable
[Laughter]
back i would yeah english before coming
to the united states
oh my god that question was worth it
just for that moment
i would i would try ventriloquist be
different but you know it is what it is
you do your best i think being a parent
you can't be perfect you just have to
try to do your best yeah it's
interesting though too because i i'm
southern a texas woman and where i don't
know if that's similar to like culture
but it's like i have a mama
and single mom as well so it's like you
i was like wait are you not yeah exactly
right very strong women yeah y'all like
to be surrounded by strong women i like
it i like it
[Music]
you